hi
i'm alexander daddario and today i'm
doing a shoot with gq
the best place to pick someone up it
seems to be
tinder weirdly enough because i know so
many people
including my sister who are in long-term
relationships off of tinder
i don't know if that's like the best
place for everybody but that seems to be
great
the best pickup line i've ever heard i
guess this is a really common one but
someone said to me
how much does a polar bear weigh enough
to break the ice hi nice to meet you
and i thought that was great just
because he said it was such irony and
cheesiness it was sort of charming
my first date was incredibly awkward i
was like 13
and i went to an all-girls school so it
was my first time like really being
around a boy for an extended period of
time it wasn't my brother
and i put on way too much makeup because
i was too excited and i think i looked
ridiculous and he later told one of my
friends that i was wearing too much
makeup and it was just really awkward
i've never had like a really bad date
and needed an exit strategy but i would
say now everyone has cell phones
right there so you just say oh my gosh i
have a friend or a family member that
really needs me it's an emergency i'm so
sorry i have to go
my ideal first date would be something
casual i guess
like a hike or if someone's willing to
do yoga with me
that's awesome i love taking people to
do yoga with me
you